hey guys dr. Berg here I have another
question about what salad mixture should
you consume and I'm just going to talk
about the different types of things that
you could put in a salad okay and the
nutrients that are involved in that we
have romaine lettuce green lettuce
cabbage spinach and kale there's arugula
there's a whole bunch of others but I
just wanted to pick the most popular and
then just kind of rate them based on how
much vitamin K which is good for
clotting and vitamin A good for the eyes
vitamin C folate potassium and
phosphorus now I'm not going to go
through all the numbers but I just
wanted to talk about out of all the
vegetables you can see whose which one
is the winner is the kale I mean it's
loaded with vitamin K I mean as a 1062
milligrams compared everything else it
just you know this is amazing so if you
were on coumadin for example because you
are on you have heart problems and
you're preventing clots
you probably want to avoid kale and
maybe you want to do something like
cabbage or green lettuce but nothing
dark green all right but kale is loaded
with vitamin K now we talked about
vitamin A spinach has the most vitamin A
but green lettuce actually comes in
second so that's pretty cool but realize
vitamin A in vegetables is a pre vitamin
A it's not an active form so you're
going to have to get your active form
through something like cod liver oil or
or eggs or something like that now when
we get to vitamin C this is interesting
yeah kale is the winner again 53
milligrams but look at cabbage comes in
second 33 compared to these other
vegetables cabbage is loaded with
vitamin C now I've recently done a lot
of videos and vitamin C deficiencies so
I think cabbage would be a great way to
get your vitamin C then we get into
folate which is romaine lettuce is
loaded with full light compared to other
things it's pretty high and then spinach
comes in second looks like kales not too
much in folate and then we get into the
potassium
you know kale has the most it's almost
three thousand three hundred and then it
has a good amount of phosphorus as well
and that would be good for energy
building bone and ligament and collagen
and things like that but the point I
wanted to make is that you need to start
consuming vegetables because check this
out in the US alone a hundred and forty
five pounds of sugar is consumed by the
average American only thirty three
pounds of lettuce is consumed by the
average American so it's not a lot and
it's probably I do probably thirty three
pounds a month myself but you want to
start increasing I would do this I would
buy big bowls okay not plates by the
bowl and fill it up and that's your
salad at least one of those a day or
maybe even two but I just wanted to
create the chart to kind of give you a
little deeper insight on the benefits of
certain types of vegetables more than
others I think kales the winner and you
should probably do that and I like
cabbage spinach is pretty good too
thanks for watching hi guys hey listen I
created a pretty amazing evaluation quiz
down below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root
cause of all of your symptoms the most
likely cause
so take the quiz now and we'll send you
report